hello I'm Donna freezin it feels like
our future rests on tests right now test
to see who is positive for Kovac 19
tests to see who has antibodies tick
Ovid 19 and might be immune no country
knows the true picture of the spread of
this virus because no country has tested
everyone here in Canada almost a million
and a half Canadians have been tested
for kovat 19 so far that's less than 4%
of the population the more you test the
easier it becomes to track the spread of
the virus and reduce transmission that's
especially important as we start to open
up the economy and get people back to
work tonight Jeff's simple dissects the
intricate anatomy of a Koba 19 test this
has become the new focal point in the
fight against kovat 19
these aren't frontline doctors or nurses
instead they're laboratory technologists
and technicians and these days they have
their hands everyone is trying to wrap
up with the testing abilities Humber
River Hospital is home to one of
Ontario's 26 labs tasked with testing
handling potentially hazardous samples
to determine whether a patient is
infected with kovat 19 we work behind
the scenes to provide results that the
doctors need and those results are now
needed badly as businesses reopen and
restrictions are lifted knowing who is
and isn't sick could mean the difference
between preventing a second wave of the
virus testing is key to understanding
when new cases arise that we can descend
upon them with overwhelming force and
suppress those handful of cases from
becoming an outbreak from the start the
priority has been testing frontline care
workers like 35 year-old Lajoie the
mother of four works in a care home for
people with disabilities and last month
she suddenly lost her sense of smell my
mother-in-law was frying fish one day
and you know how fish smells I couldn't
smell it and I was like why can't I
smell it and then when I was trying to
eat I couldn't taste it and I know I
didn't have a cold at that point and it
lasted a long time so that's when I knew
that something was clearly wrong any
symptoms at all so Lajoie came to this
assessment center to be tested for Co
vid 19 the test itself is pretty simple
a quick albeit uncomfortable swab of the
throat or the sinuses you have to open
right and ya
the whole process is over in less than
30 seconds but the sample placed in this
test tube still has a long way to go
only high-risk patients the very sick
requiring surgery will have their tests
processed here the rest are labeled
placed in a cooler bag and picked up by
a courier then driven to different labs
across Toronto where they joined the
queue not all Lots have the capacity to
process large volumes of of samples so
that might influence the delay on
results and capacity remains a concern
when test results arrive at the Humber
River Hospital lab they're taken to a
separate area through three sets of
protective doors and negative pressure
rooms first staff put on their
protective gear then carefully move the
nasal swab from the test tube into one
of these cartridges before placing it
into this specialized machine which
analyzes the DNA for two genes connected
to kovat 19 it doesn't take long this is
the m2 gene and this is the e gene so
specifically it's detected and it's
giving a result of a positive result it
takes less than an hour to reveal the
patient is positive but this is the labs
only machine from an American
manufacturer and it can only process 16
tests at a time and the tests themselves
are in short supply prior to this year
there was nobody developing that test so
every company that's now developing that
test has had to ramp up production their
supply chain issues and there's huge
demand for the test it's as simple as
that the result this high-tech lab which
conducts more than 10,000 tests for
other diseases each week can only
process around 200 weekly tests per
kovat 19 I do wish that we had more
testing capability so that we could be
more informed with our decision making
we're going to ramp up this testing like
this problems has never seen
Ontario and Quebec the provinces hardest
hit by the pandemic are also having the
toughest time with testing no you don't
need it at this Quebec care home worker
lied about having symptoms so she could
receive a test and her result came back
positive I couldn't believe the fact
that I had to fight and lie to get a
test
her story underscores the importance of
testing because many cases are mild or
even symptom free we need to do
surveillance testing we need to try and
get a measure of that portion of the
iceberg that's under the water
those asymptomatic cases we need to do
that before we open Alberta is now doing
just that
testing residents in Calgary and Brooks
regardless of symptoms lessened the
criteria for testing which is key they
have allowed a greater number of
laboratories to participate the testing
process for a while in Ontario for
example only the public health labs were
engaged in the testing capacity but we
needed to loosen up those criteria to
commercial labs University labs it's all
hands on deck scenario after three days
of waiting l'homme ease test result came
back positive I was scared
to be honest with you because I have my
mother-in-law I have my children that
was back on April 14th after a couple of
weeks her symptoms disappeared and she
went back for a second test but those
results came back positive again all
they told me is that now that I already
finished my two weeks isolation and I
have no symptoms whatsoever that I
couldn't go out in the community but
make sure that we do social distancing
you can't blow this one if she's now
been tested five times all of them
positive
fortunately her husband tested negative
and her children never developed
symptoms I'm just waiting for that
negative so I can really get back to
work the molecular test is so sensitive
that it can pick up viral genetic
material even in the absence of somebody
being sick and the hospital lab director
says they're about to add a new test
serologic a made in italy blood test
just approved by Health Canada that
checks a patient for
antibodies that tells you how many
people have have been exposed and have
hopefully partial or complete immunity
versus people who haven't been exposed
and it helps you more with public policy
decision-making this lab plans to start
conducting serologic antibody tests by
the end of the month the better the
testing the greater our understanding of
a virus that in many ways remains a
mystery
[Music]